les rues de lesbos se vide peu à peu de
ses milliers de réfugiés sans abri selon
les autorités de l'île grecque et 5000
migrants ont désormais intégré le
nouveau camp sur le site de karaté p une
installation en bord de mer composé de
tentes blanches montées à la hâte par la
grèce et le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés de l'onu
poussé par l'épuisement d'une dizaine de
jours passés dans la rue sous un soleil
écrasant
certains exilés ont fini par intégrer la
structure
d'autres tentent de résister par crainte
d'être de nouveau coincé plusieurs mois
dans l'attenté d'un éventuel transfert
nous devons aller dans le corps si nous
n'y allons pas notre demande d'asile
sera rejeté or leur politique consiste à
vous donner faim à nous fournir de la
nourriture qu'aux personnes se trouvant
à l'intérieur du camp pour vous inciter
à vous rendre dans cette zone
moi je n'ai vraiment pas le choix je
vais peut-être trop tard j'ai fini par
un traité
mais pour l'instant je suis encore en
éradiquant en dehors d'un camp mais pour
combien de temps encore l'évacuation des
réfugiés vers la nouvelle installation
semble s'accélérer
des milliers d'exilés sans abri sont
tirés de leur sommeil pour être conduits
vers la nouvelle structure que les
autorités promettent provisoire au total
ce sont douze mille 700 demandeurs
d'asile qui ont fui le camp de moria le
plus grand d'europe
complètement détruit par les flammes il
ya une dizaine de jours alain 110
prémédité selon les autorités grecques
six jeunes migrants afghans ont été
arrêtés dont quatre mises en examen pour
incendie volontaire est toujours
concernant ce dossier plusieurs
organisations dénoncé hier le manque d'
aide juridique proposé aux migrants pour
leur demande d'asile dans ce nouveau
camp médecins sans frontières a de son
côté alerter sur l'extrême précarité des
exilés sur l'île grecque
la situation est extrêmement compliqué
nous demeurons très préoccupé au sujet
de l'accès aux services de base pour la
population laissées sans abri après des
incendies à la suite à ça y est
il ya des milliers de personnes qui ont
déménagé dans le nouveau camp construit
par les autorités grecques sur un
nouveau site
la police a demandé à ces personnes de
se déplacer il y a des limites dans le
camp quant à l'assistance humanitaire il
s'agit donc de conditions fondamentales
les gens bien évidemment demande
toujours la liberté ils ont été très
réticents à l'idée
de déménager dans le camp